je vous la fais courte
j'ai fondé les gardiens
j'ai rencontré une fille je vais tomber
amoureux cette fille est morte et puis
elle est revenue
sauf qu'elle est devenue tarée
commences-tu tu as oublié quelques infos
importantes mais tu as résumé
l'essentiel
ma mission sacrée
c'est de créer la société parfaite
c'est pas qu'il aimait la perfection
c'est plutôt qu'il détestait les choses
telles qu'elles sont
je veux que vous sachiez tout ce que je
suis honoré de me battre aux côtés de
mes amis incinérer
[Musique]
on a toujours été en quête d'une famille
jusqu'à ce qu'on se rencontre
vous êtes prêts pour une dernière virée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous nous envolerons tous ensemble
à travers l'infinité
c'est merveilleux ciel
[Musique]
je sais pas trop de qui était amoureux
mais ça ressemble plus à elle quoi
même pas en rêve j'avais jamais remarqué
que tu avais de beaux yeux noirs